and beginning now on book TV it's the
final talk of the day from the 15th
annual Annapolis Book Festival it's a
discussion on music and technology with
Thomas Dolby
good to see them
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen and
welcome to the next panel here at the
Annapolis Book Festival I'm Alex
Kortright of 89 seven wtmd and if you
are interested in a life a most
remarkable life spent at the
intersection of music and technology
well friends you are in the right place
we are here to talk about this brand new
book the speed of sound breaking the
barriers between music and technology by
Thomas Dolby musician songwriter MTV
star collaborator husband father
technologist entrepreneur professor this
is just a bit of the metadata that we
can attach to the name Thomas Dolby this
is a remarkable memoir and I thought we
should begin with a choice anecdote this
is actually how you begin your memoir
you are you find yourself in the blazing
heat of the Nevada desert desperately
trying to communicate over a phone line
a phone booth you guys remember phone
booths you're battling off fire ants
you've just written a song for someone
and you're having a hard time getting
through to this individual tell us that
story yes so this was the morning after
a gig that we did at the Greek Theatre
in Los Angeles and backstage at the
Greek Theatre was none other than
Michael Jackson and he said to me he was
he you know to my astonishment he knew
the names of some of my songs and he
asked me if I had any extra songs
knocking around I'm like bull sure I do
Michael
he said you got anything like
hyperactive you know I like the groove
you know it so happens I've got one
exactly like hyperactive said well when
can I hear it I said what you know I can
make a demo in the back of my tour bus
and I can send it to you from my
personal computer and I had a personal
computer which was a from Radio Shack
you know one of those things with a
QWERTY and little little screen and
acoustic couplers which were these
rubber pads that you would plug the
receiver into so I spent half the night
making a demo
back on my tour bus and I got the driver
to pull over by the side of the road in
a cloud of dust at a phone booth halfway
to Salt Lake City and armed with my
acoustic cups and my Radio Shack
computer I attempted to send this file
over a phone line to Michael Jackson at
the record plant in Los Angeles and I
had I remember I was wearing corduroy
trousers and the pockets were bulging
with quarters and I would kept pumping
them in and I was having a hard time
getting this file to transfer I mean
this is 1980 before or something like
that so it's no big surprise and Michael
said well why don't you just do it the
old-fashioned way just sing me the tune
and I thought oh no what have I got
myself into so I took a deep breath and
I started sort of banging on the mic
like this and I'm like like making up
the words is like go along you know in
the time-honored fashion and there's
sort of this silence at the end of the
line and finally he said got anything
else your beginnings in music well they
were humble in fact the very first
synthesizer you came across because
quite frankly the technology was
expensive was actually in a dumpster
yeah well this is in the winter of
discontent in London when there were
various strikes going on including a
garbage strike and you could find the
most amazing things just stacked up on
street corners and in dumpsters and it
was in one such dumpster that I found a
circuit board which as it turned out was
the guts of a machine called a
transcendent 2000 and that I took it
home and soldered it together and it was
my first ever synthesizer had no
keyboard mind you you made noises by
twiddling knobs and pressing buttons
sort of bleeps and blips but I was happy
as a clam know right I find one of the
anecdotes in your book especially
interesting and maybe illuminating you
came from a family of academics maybe
they might have been a little suspicious
of this interest in music as a
profession for example but the very
first time his family saw him perform
was actually on a show in the UK called
Top of the Pops which was like Ed
Sullivan for us a decade before I mean
it's something that everybody watched a
big show you were on performing a song
you had written for Lena Levitch called
new toy which became quite a hit that
was the first time your family saw you
perform on Top of the Pops yes it
probably the first time they took me
seriously actually my father and his
father and his father were all Cambridge
professors and my mother taught algebra
and statistics and I have one of the
youngest of six kids and they were all
academic in one to one level or another
so I was sort of the black sheep of the
family I left school at 16 to go work in
a fruit and vegetable shop in Notting
Hill Gate to sort of feed my nighttime
punk-rock habit and so during the day I
worked in this store and and you know at
night I would go and see the Sex Pistols
and the clash and actually at that time
everybody was kind of punk you know if
you didn't have long hair and flared
trousers you must be a punk rocker you
know so Elvis Costello was a punk the
police were punks etc when I saw all of
them in little pubs around where I lived
in London so it's a fantastic time but
my parents you know were kind of waiting
for me to get a proper job and I think
the night that they finally saw me on
top of the pops along with maybe a third
of the UK watching at that moment I
think that was the first time they
really they knew that I was not bluffing
this is really gonna be a career that I
was gonna pursue right right well your
your initial thrust towards pop success
didn't work out exactly as planned and
you find yourself busking in the
Parisian Metro but there you get a phone
call from one Mick Jones you're thinking
oh my gosh the clash is reaching out to
me not so much it turned out to be the
other Mick Jones the one that played in
foreigner the American AOR rock group
and so I was a little bit disappointed
to be perfectly honest sorry Mick I
thought didn't they have like a song
called cold as ice or something like
that and but they said you know could I
to get in the next plane to New York and
do some session keyboard playing on a
now on the foreigner for which was their
latest album and I didn't really want to
go actually I thought that you know this
busking thing was just temporary in any
minute I was gonna get signed up by a
record label and I've been making my own
stuff so my friend Joe that I bust with
said if you don't really want to go why
don't you just quote them the [ __ ] off
price
sorry cameras and that sort of you know
and they said yes you know it actually
became like a motto of mine that I
returned too many times over the years
when I didn't really want to go anywhere
yeah today being the exception because I
couldn't couldn't wait to come down to
Annapolis well they paid and you have
provided some synthesizers you really
warmed up to some of these foreigner
tracks then became quite famous and very
successful with that money in turn you
were able to then focus on your thing
and you were able to record that first
record the Golden Age of wireless which
sold modestly in fact if I'm not
mistaken it was well on its way to
number one in Guatemala and were it not
for an unfortunate coup d'etat it might
have gotten to the top of the charts you
were a fan of silent movies hmm I know
that you loved Buster Keaton artists
like that and when this new thing called
MTV began to pop you were interested and
you began to think well maybe I could
provide something for this and that
really began the ascent of Thomas Dolby
yes so my album had come out and have
been very well reviewed and sold about
three copies and it wasn't getting much
radio play in the US and radio radio
play was really the key you know to the
charts in the USA it counted towards the
Billboard charts but it also really was
proportionate to sales as well but MTV
came along and for the first time in
major cities cool people were staying at
home on a Saturday night to watch MTV
videos instead of going out to gigs and
clubs
and so MTV was very influential and I
could see this and I could see that
people that were successful MTV was
starting to get radio play as a result
and then end up in the charts and but a
lot of the videos on MTV weren't that
inspiring I always had this sort of
hankering you know to be a silent movie
star like Keaton or Lloyd or Chaplin or
whatever and part of that was really
because this is 1981 you know that the
pinup front men of the day were people
like Adam Ann I'm staying in Simon Lebon
and I didn't feel I was going to sort of
compete in the in the handsome boy
stakes so I might as well latch on to
this sort of scientific slightly
professorial image which was after all
part of my gene pool you know and so I
made a video which sort of started out
as a storyboard I thought well if okay
if I'm gonna be viewed as a scientist
I'm gonna be a hip scientist so I need
like a hot Japanese lab assistant and a
cool vintage motorcycle with sidecar and
so on and so I sort of created this this
parallel life for myself and I wrote a
storyboard in which this character went
to this sort of this loony asylum and
there was a sinister operation featuring
this sort of Mad Professor psychiatrist
type I wrote the storyboard for this and
took its my record label EMI and begged
them to give me the budget to write and
direct this video myself and they said
well this is great but Thomas where's
the song I said I'll bring it in on
Monday morning that's that and so I
basically had the weekend to write a
song and I had a title she blinded me
with science but I didn't really have a
song so I went back to my little home
studio and wrote it and took it in on
the Monday morning I'm detecting a
certain pattern here yeah are you sure I
have the song I'll be right back and of
course she blinded me with science
became a breakthrough hit Tom five hit
in the United States and it was then
added to the golden age of wireless the
first pressing did not have that song
but then that enabled the album to also
chart and then off you went
hyperactive was a follow-up single
a couple of years later and at least by
my estimation it should have been a top
10 hit in the u.s. a great song it did
very well in the UK but here you were
perhaps for the first time given a real
hard look at the nature of the music
industry with all of its whims and
vagaries and well a business that at
times could be dirty and vindictive yeah
tell us a little bit about what happened
to hyperactive here in the US well you
know when you have a hit record
everybody slaps each other on the pack
and they go out and celebrate right and
you just the art from an artists
standpoint you assume wallets because it
was a great song it's a great
performance I got what I deserved and
had a hit record when a song flops you
immediately start to do a post-mortem
and analyze what went wrong and as I dug
into the reasons that possibly
hyperactive hadn't done so well I
started to come face to face with some
of the sort of grim reality of the music
industry when I saw what hadn't gone
right for that single and it was
depressing to me quite frankly and I and
I think probably i overstepped to mark
that artists you know are expected not
to cross generally when that happens
they'll just commiserate with you and
they say well when you go back in the
studio make us some more hits and we'll
do better next time you know but I sort
of dug into it and what I began to
realize was that just as all the Ducks
had been in a row four she blinded me
with science several things went wrong
with hyperactive including a lot of sort
of political wrangling between the
record companies and a rather strange
organisation called the network now the
network was populated with guys who in
theory were radio experts so they were
independent consultants that a record
company would go to in order to figure
out what which song off an album to
picked to go on the radio whether it
needed editing what sort of segments of
the radio world they should approach
with it and so on and basically without
the network you couldn't have a hit
record because in fact what was
happening was they indirectly controlled
what actually got played on the radio
and there are a lot of sort of brown
envelopes changing hands and so on and
it was really upsetting to find this out
because when you find out something like
that you realize that well maybe it
wasn't on the merits of my music or my
words or my performance that the other
one was a hit and this one wasn't maybe
it was just that the right palms got
greased so I started to become you know
disillusioned with the music industry
and I started looking elsewhere right
right however with that said this
success this this pop hit with she blind
me with science
well got you noticed in a lot of
quarters and you were able to do some
amazing things during the eighties some
amazingly techie for example you were
invited to play Live Aid with David
Bowie at Wembley you are asked to
connect musically with Stevie Wonder and
Herbie Hancock you're asked to perform
at the wall at the Berlin Wall when
Roger Waters brought that Pink Floyd
masterpiece back you worked with Joni
Mitchell you worked with Jerry Garcia
and Bob Weir kind of this line of
Legends and that must have been enormous
ly satisfying yeah I mean these were the
legends of my teen years you know and I
still don't know about you guys but I
still have a certain adulation for the
stuff that I loved when I was 15 which I
find it hard to replicate with you know
with any new music today and it's not
necessarily a judgment on the music I
just think that at that age we're
especially you know influential
influenceable
and so it was incredibly flattering to
avataq attracted as he said the you know
the attention of some of my heroes and
to get to play with them and to see what
I could do to enhance what they did you
know for example Joni Mitchell who I'd
adored since I was maybe 12 or 13 I
think I think blue was the first album I
ever bought with my own pocket money
she'd had a succession of musical
collaborators like Tom Scott like Jaco
Pastorius and so on who had sort of
flavored an era of her of her work for
music and so when I got invited to work
with her
I pictured myself
was being you know the flavor of the
hopefully you know the decayed it turned
out to more like to be more like three
months we didn't really click
unfortunately but she was astonishing to
be around had endless unbelievable
stories I mean true but unbelievable
stories about you know when she was
living in a cave on a Greek island right
in Cary and stuff like that or the night
that Miles Davis passed out in a Paris
hotel suite with his hand gripped around
her ankle and she had to call the house
detective to come and prize his his bony
fingers off her ankle so she was great
to be around a fabulous artist and
completely deserves
you know the accolades that she's had
from generations of singer songwriters
that are sort of followed in her
footsteps so yeah like you say it was it
was really very gratifying to to be able
to work with people like that
you have to tell the story of explaining
to George Clinton that he in fact was
not about to be abducted by the
mothership connection they was actually
bioluminescence well I went to saw I co
produced some songs on George's album
some of my best jokes are friends and we
did this down in Miami and what George
would do on his days off is go fishing
fishing he would charter a fishing boat
Naggar tuna fishing and this would be
like a big big boat but and we go miles
out but you could still see the
skyscrapers of Miami behind you you know
and this was his way to relax and he'd
have a big blaster and he'd be playing
rough mixes from the night before and
every now and then you know the captain
was shout fish on and George would press
a button and electorate reel would
really in like a giant you know and he'd
sort of bat it over the head and throw
it on the ice and there you know I I
felt this wasn't very sporting I sort of
thought well if at least if you did it
from a kayak you know it might be
somewhat more you know well they call it
sport fishing I have no idea they seem
really so but he George told me about a
night that he went out in the Bermuda
Triangle with Bootsy Collins in a
chartered fishing boat and that they got
enveloped by a silver cloud
and globs of mercury were falling out of
the sky and spattering on the deck and
they were convinced that this was a an
attempted alien abduction and the the
skipper at the boat was drunk and locked
himself in the engine room and they had
to navigate their way back to land after
having had this close encounter I said
yeah that George have you ever heard of
bioluminescence and he said what's that
and I said you know it's like these
organisms that live in the sea they
absorb the light during the day so at
night they glow you know sometimes you
see a trail of them and those can splash
on the boat and it looks kind of eerie
you guys oh so what about the the silver
cloud and I said well I mean if you're
in a fog bank and there was a full moon
then it would appear that you're in the
midst of a silver cloud and a couple
that were the globs of green
luminescence on the day it would be you
know given I don't know what you were on
but I could see that that would be a
pretty weird experience and he said Toby
you ain't no fun man you blinded him
with science apparently so you of course
continue to make records throughout the
eighties brilliant albums but there was
also a sense that you know the music biz
mmm you were beginning to be attracted
to what was happening in Northern
California Silicon Valley of course you
were using a lot of the technology that
was coming out of there and your
synthesizers and that kind of thing
there was this kind of a natural
affinity tell us how you made that
transition to Silicon Valley well yeah I
mean as you say I'd been using software
and hardware that had come out of
Silicon Valley you know in the early
days of my music I was using most mostly
custom kit like the circuit board from
the transcendent 2000 I sold it together
but as time went on the equipment that
my fans were using was tons converged
with what I was using to make it on so
by the late 80s I had an Apple Mac you
know and a lot of my audience were out
there with an Apple Mac as well and the
software was becoming cheaper and more
freely available and yet it didn't
always do what I wanted it to do so I
would often go up to Silicon Valley and
consults with companies like Digidesign
and
code and so on and I would make feature
requests which if I was lucky six months
later there be a rather the software
that included my request so I sort of
got bitten by the bug so simultaneously
I was getting disillusioned with the
music industry I was getting really
excited with what was going on in
Silicon Valley and this remember was the
early days of the Internet so the
internet I took a look at that and I
thought ok once were all connected
why can't I just send my files from my
Apple Mac via the Internet to your Apple
Mac and now suddenly bypassed this music
industry that I was so you know
disillusioned with and I've just
connected directly with my audience now
I was kind of right about that I was
just off by about 15 years or something
like that but I saw no reason of course
why this shouldn't change overnight so I
was really more excited about that and
so I went to Silicon Valley and formed
my own software company which was
eventually called beatnik yeah so
beatnik initially was our product and
what it was designed to do was to make
webpages sauna fied so that instead of
just clicking around on the web you
would actually be generating sound
effects and music as he went and in
order to do this you had to have a
synthesizer that worked in software not
a synthesizer with a keyboard and lots
of knobs like a hardware thing but just
a chunk of code that would download in
your web page and would trigger these
sounds and so that was our that was our
technology and through much of the 90s
we were pushing this technology and
getting millions of downloads and
throwing big parties and press releases
and we had a revenue of 0 billion
dollars right and yet this this beatnik
synthesizer is very small very efficient
eventually it would find a home inside
of about 2 billion cell phones worldwide
yeah well it came about in a strange way
and a lot of people sort of assume when
you have a tech success story that you
know some genius was in a garage in
Cupertino and a light bulb popped but in
fact it was much more arbitrary than
that so we've been struggling you know
in the dot-com world and we'd created a
very small and very efficient stuff
we're synthesizer while other
synthesizers on the market were growing
and growing and getting more powerful as
processors got more powerful so in about
1998 the world's largest cell phone
manufacturer Nokia in Finland was
looking for a way to do ringtones in
their phones they'd seen some Japanese
phones coming out that had a Yamaha MIDI
chip in them that were able to play
melodic ringtones and but they didn't
want to have the expense in the
liability of a dedicated hardware chip
in each unit so they looked for a
software synthesizer that was small and
efficient enough to play ringtones in
their phones and we really had the only
solution so in about 98 we sent
engineers to Finland to see if they
could port our technology to the
mass-market Nokia phones and the long
and the short of it was that Nokia
licensed it and embedded it in their
phones and shipped several hundred
million of them and saved beatniks bacon
because we would have sort of gone the
way of many other coms if it were not
for this one deal right right and you
mentioned ringtones you did form another
company called retro ringtones where
which would I think in some measure was
the payoff for all of this hard work in
Silicon Valley and it there's an
interesting story about the ringtone
phenomenon because you may remember 10
12 13 years ago kids were willing to
spend two dollars and 50 cents on a
rather poor sounding slice of a song of
a pop song maybe mm maybe someone else
but not 99 cents for the actual song for
a wav file you make a really interesting
point about that well yeah I mean you
know the music industry couldn't figure
this out they couldn't figure out
because they were trying to launch
platforms to sell music for 99 cents and
they were failing dismally and they can
work out why ringtones like this
substandard rendition of a hit were
selling by the bucketload for two and a
half bucks a pop and it really hit me
one Christmas season when I was shopping
with my family
in a mall in Northern California and I
was sort of burnt out by their snow
sitting on a bench and there was a group
of kids across the way in front of it
like a sports door and somebody's phone
went off when it was an Eminem song now
he's a rapper you know so like a bleep
II version of one of his songs this is
really a poor substitute but at that
moment I realized that this teenager
like if her phone's gonna go off in the
midst of her friends it's really
important that it's the right ringtone
same way as that logo on her sneakers
has to be that N or that tick because
even though she could have saved twenty
bucks and got a knockoff you know the
brand is important and so I realized
that that two-and-a-half bucks
wasn't coming from her music budget cuz
she has no music budget she can get all
the music in the world she wants for
free off the internet but she does have
a fashion budget you know like a closed
budget and that's where that 250 came
from and that was what the music
industry couldn't understand they could
not get their head around that at all
and retro ringtones did and that was a
nice payoff for you finally um there
were a lot of highs and a lot of lows
during this period measured I mean
really you were one of the very first to
bring sound to the Internet period if
I'm not mistaken it was it was a 7-up
thing a campaign with with that Jamaican
guy don't you feel good about a 7-up you
remember that one yeah you guys push
that and the technologists at the time
also couldn't quite get their head
around why would you want sound on the
internet they didn't even want speakers
in the computers really you know they
said to me that speakers would annoy the
guy in the next cubicle while he's
crunching numbers in his spreadsheet you
know that they saw sound as a
distraction at the only tech company
that really took sound and music
seriously were Apple and everybody
viewed them as sort of hippy dreamers
you know the investors would come to my
office and they say Thomas you need to
get the max off the desktop because if
we see that we think you know this guy
is just a dreamer the Fanta cyst fast
forward 20 years you know who's the
biggest company in the world and what
was their killer app Oh
right right you also got involved in the
TED talks early on especially after it
had left the kind of rarefied air of
Silicon Valley and became sort of open
to the public and became a nonprofit in
fact you were the musical director for
about a dozen years which maybe moves
you a little closer to the idea of the
family business
we'll get to that point in a moment but
that was it that was a really unique
period you were I think you described it
was as sprinkling fairy dust on the
proceedings yeah so I gave my first TED
talk in 1992 with this software engine
that I'd created and I saw the power of
it and Ted was a fantastic thing but it
was sort of a bit elitist it was a bit
of a boys club very hidden mystic you
know you had to know somebody to get in
and pay thousands of dollars and we
would listen to talks and then we go off
and drive a concept car around a
racetrack or or get flown around
Monterey Bay or you know have a
fantastic cocktail party at the aquarium
so and it was entrepreneurs and Silicon
Valley VCS and so on so Chris Anderson
who I already knew is a Brit
he had become a success as a magazine
editor and he had a magazine called
business 2.0 in Silicon Valley at the
time was sort of a bit like Wired or
something like that and he took over the
conference and he made it his mission to
turn it from a very closed-door
for-profit event into a non-profit and
to attempt to share the sort of
intellectual capital of Ted with the
world in a free way without diluting the
desirability of being there at the event
so I helped Chris out with some of the
staging and the music and so on and if
you spend four or five days at Ted the
intellectual stimulation is so
overpowering sometimes that it's very
refreshing to have you know a Scottish
folk singer go up and sing to you for 15
minutes and so my job was really to
bring in musicians and to create custom
music sort of over tours for each
session and you did just that you
created music for the
and brought in people like David Byrne
and Paul Simon and many others yeah you
wanted to have people that would stick
around for four days and rub shoulders
with the astronauts and coral reef
explorers and genetic physicists and
things like that right right you know I
can't help but think that there is a
direct link between Ted and all of that
intellectual stimulation and the
coupling with music which is something
you came from and your current tenure as
a Johns Hopkins University professor hmm
not tenure but said her current position
thank you
yes so I got invited just over three
years ago to lecture at Johns Hopkins
University in Baltimore and to help them
launch a new film Center so I'm actually
in the film department currently and I
teach film scoring to students both from
Johns Hopkins and mica the local art
school and I've been doing that for two
and a half years I'm switching as of the
full to create a new program at the
Peabody Conservatory which is also part
of Johns Hopkins and that is a program
in music for new media meaning film TV
but also computer games and virtual
reality and so on
EEG music was therapy all such things
like that and I was very intrigued by
this opportunity I felt that I reached a
time in my life where I'd sort of run
out of new fields to barge my way into
and it was maybe time to give a little
bit back and hope some of that
experience and wisdom could rub rub off
on a new generation of kids on top of
which my wife is from New York she had
some her family had some health issues
she wanted to be close to them so it
really made sense for us to you know to
move to Baltimore and it's been a big
success and we absolutely love it there
you you told me is six seven months ago
that one of the reasons you wanted to
take this position is because you could
perhaps well for example put them in or
in a room and lock out their cell phones
they actually have to think about
problems in a way
perhaps you and I did coming up it is
different with that we and without our
Google brain it becomes a different
world
I also liked about what you said about
how how teaching music and imparting
some of this wisdom is fulfilling on a
very different level hmm
if you'd comment on that well one of the
things I say with my students is that
when they encounter problems or
roadblocks they're just a few key
presses away from the solution
you know you google it you download the
user manual you post a message in a
forum you go on YouTube when you find
somebody that solved the problem for you
so they don't really expect encounter
any any hurdles really and but I look
back at my career and I realized that
all the most creative things that I've
been able to achieve have been because I
hit a roadblock and I had to sort of
circumnavigate and it was really off the
beaten path well there was no manual not
exactly in terms of making videos for
MTV yeah very few had done it yeah
internals of bringing sound to the
internet no one had really done it yeah
so and I mean I I I screwed up at times
as well but I sometimes even the
screw-ups would result in interesting
you know artifacts and if you're alert
to that and you have a good sort of nose
for it you can uncover some real gems
and I think it's especially valid now
for anybody that's creative because
although we've all got this fabulous
software you know on our computers on
our phones 99-cent apps that you know do
more than $100,000 Fairlight did you
know in 1982 it's fantastic the downside
is that everybody else in the room in
fact everybody in the state in fact
everybody across the whole planet has
got access to that same 99-cent app so
there's a real tendency for things to be
funneled into us at a mediocre middle
ground where everything is very generic
and that's that's poison for an artist
you know when you when you're in an
overpopulated field like that it's it's
really deadly and people get defensive
and they get say me and they get
formulaic and it's really the antithesis
of originality and great art I'm about
to open up the floor to questions if
anyone wants to ask Thomas Dolby a
question or two but first you mentioned
a lot of people in your book and my
guess is a lot of these people will not
be writing their own memoir or
autobiography did anyone reach out to
you to fix themselves
yeah actually funnily enough I mean uh
my first draft I gave to half a dozen or
so people that I trusted to give me good
input and most of them are mentioned in
the book and the first thing they wanted
to do was fix themselves in the book but
it was interesting that people have very
different memories and recalls of the
same event and I realized that many of
the stories in the book you know they're
stories that I've told verbally either
you know in a social setting or in an
interview like this or whatever and so
your memory almost becomes solidified
with the evolution of that story you
know as you get better at telling it
over the years so sometimes these were
people that were actually there and they
go you know I've read before when you've
said that that's the way it's happened
and Thomas that's actually not the way
it happened which is you know that's a
function of memory and I mean you see
this in in court cases you know it's
like somebody will stand they'll be on
the stand and on the Bible they say you
know a green truck came out of the
driveway and turned left and then they
show the video and it's a red truck and
it turned right does anyone ever able to
provide evidence contrary to your memory
I don't think so particularly I mean my
manager in the 80s was extremely anal
and kept every file and every meeting
note you know going back to 1980 and he
still has it in his attic why I don't
know he just can't let them go he's a
hoarder I guess and when I was writing
the first draft if I couldn't you know a
lot of the dates and things I could look
up on the internet but if there was a
date or a name that I didn't know I just
fill something in and I thought well
Andy you'll set me right you know so I
sent my first draft to Andy and it came
back with a hundred and thirty nine
notes
in the margin and his comments got more
and more abusive as time went on the
beginning they're quite polite but by
the end it was like where do you get
this crap and and it became apparent to
me that he hit reply and sent it back to
me knowing full well that I might never
talk to him again
but actually I was very grateful to be
put right about many of those things
yeah right any regrets about something
you included or didn't include in this
book well I mean
touchwood you know I haven't had any
lawsuits yet a lawyer went over it and
and picked out a few things and sort of
said you know the name of one person he
said you might want to change this to a
more generic name because she's very
litigious and she's gonna come after you
and so that you'll see it a Hollywood
diva is mentioned in the book and that's
that's the only name I give her all
right this is something I asked you a
couple of years ago um whether or not
you were writing new music and at the
time you said well you know things are
kind of bubbling up sometimes I'll be in
the shower and a melody will strike me
are you making music quite little I tend
to work when there is sort of a sucking
sound I mean go back to the the video
thing I mean a process that I use when
I'm creating is I sort of picture the
moment at which the public will
experience this thing that I'm creating
and I sort of work backwards from there
so if I'm writing a song for example
I've visualized a stage an empty
spotlight a grand piano and a guy walks
onto the stage and sits himself at the
grand piano and starts to play and sing
what does it sound like I just imagine
that sound that intro he starts to sing
what what's the line you know and start
sort of reverse engineer that moment and
work backwards from there so if there
isn't that sucking sound then I tend to
be not so not so productive so right now
I have no record label I have no tour
lined up it's not like there's a vast
global audience that are just like
pressurizing me to come out with a new
album I'm not done with music by any
chance
there will be more but at this
particular moment in time there are
other things that sort of thrill me more
including the teaching including writing
you know I wrote this book having never
written anything published anything
before other than the odd blog and I had
a blast doing it and I want to do more
of that and I really enjoy you know
anything that I suck at is is really
challenging and stimulating to me
what do you suck at while still writing
actually you know I mean writing a
memoir is one thing but I think it
differs well a fine piece of work thank
you thank you but actually much my next
one is gonna be fiction and that is
really hard Oh interesting
yeah okay folks I'd like to open the
floor to questions if anyone has a
question I think you might need to grab
the microphone in the middle there or
just walk up to the mic I really liked
your point about towards the end about
the mediocrity of content that's being
produced and as a result of the
technology available so I wonder what do
you say to your students who are trying
to produce content music or whatever no
why would they
why do they do that I'm a musician a
technology person and why do they
why why why create oh I create a tool
when there's such a sea of I'll show
mediocre stuff and social media and
everybody has to answer that question
for themselves really you know I think
there is a there is a flow a constant
flow of new talent coming forward I mean
there are people who are on this planet
to make great music and you know they'll
be wave after wave but we may go through
phases of you know a golden age or a
rather sparse period you know we're not
much exciting music is actually being
made and sometimes that relates to
technology sometimes it relates to
politics sometimes it relates to what
other areas have grabbed the public's
interest you know more than music a lot
of young people today spend their time
playing video games or in social
networks or watching reality TV and you
know when I was a kid there wasn't very
much
to do other than wait for the new you
know Grateful Dead album to come out or
see if you could save enough money to go
see the The Allman Brothers at Knebworth
festival or what you know we're obsessed
with those things and we would tribe
together with other kids that felt the
same way
so those things were rarefied and they
really focused on our attention and I
think that you know if you're that age
today you just have so many more options
and so many more choices so it's
somewhat D values the music doesn't
necessarily mean that good music doesn't
get made but it it you know it's like
it's like if the market is flooded with
diamonds then diamonds lose their value
it's the same thing so I haven't really
answered your question how do I
encourage them to do you know you just
have to you just have to follow your
instinct if your impulse is to make
music then you got to go and do it and
and you know the equipment is there to
do it the publishing means are there to
do it so at least you don't have to like
get a cassette to an A&R guy or or you
know whatever those kinds of things that
we had to deal with so in some ways is
better but in other ways it's much much
tougher than it ever was Thomas thank
you for coming to the Q school if you I
have a few points first and I'm not sure
where I lived that was different than
the rest of the world that hyperactive
was our go-to song every Friday in
college and kept us going throughout the
weekend second piece when will you be
reuniting with the jazz mafia horns it's
like you did it South by Southwest
that was quite creative and ties into
probably the first question how you know
where you were tongue I think the title
of this is thinking outside the box and
certainly at the key school that's one
of the things that my children learn
down to do and I haven't quite coped
with that yet but how do you foster sort
of that you know in your students or
encouraged them to push their boundaries
and go beyond what is conventional and
to think outside the box and Alex thanks
for coming - yeah you know in the area
of film music as distinct from music as
a whole so what I've been teaching them
so
far we've been sort of looking at what
the role is of music in films and TV and
what it's really there for it's a very
interesting time for television and the
whole sort of cadence of storytelling
character arcs and in fact music is
different again in episodic TV than it
is from films but many of them have
never given much thought to the
contribution that music makes to films
there are the obvious things like it
establishing time in place and so on
creating moods but if you're a filmmaker
it's really vital that you learn how to
relate to composers and how to talk to
musicians same ways you have to learn
how to talk to an actor even if you're
not an actor so we've been sort of
focused on that really and I encourage
them to experiment with their point of
view see what they can do to enhance the
drama the drama the emotion in a scene
and I'll typically you know for example
take a scene from a movie with no music
send them off in pairs to an edit suite
for an hour and a half with the internet
switched off no phones and tell them in
an hour and a half they're going to come
back and project it on a big screen for
the whole class to critique and I'd like
them to take two or three different
types of approaches and see if they can
vary the empathy that we feel for a
certain character on the screen maybe
create subtext like suggests something
off-camera that we don't see and so on
and get them to think outside the box
really and and that means overcoming
your fear of screwing up
Johns Hopkins students have a
deep-seated fear of growing up they're
super smart super intense and they're
almost embarrassed to speak up in class
because their roommates might ridicule
them so the micro students on the other
hand have got sort of green hair and
piercings and they go yeah mister you
know so they're kinda they rub off on
each other so that's kind of great but
um so that you know that's as far as as
film music now this is gonna broaden out
as of next year when I have a whole
department to work
and those will be largely classical
students classical musicians who are
looking for alternative career paths in
making music for games virtual reality
enhanced reality even working with
geriatric patients or stroke victims to
see how they can use music to help the
healing process so I've taken away I
think the principles that I've developed
over the last two or three years in my
film music class and expand those to a
wider spectrum of types of different
careers that they're going to follow
when they leave University interesting
yes sir well I was gonna ask that same
question how do you balance technology
and the organic feel of expressing
yourself personally I'm electronic
engineer I have all the stuff in my
house to do it but there's a blockage
between technology and being analytic
and expressing my son any pointers yeah
I mean for me you know it's interesting
you say that because at this point in my
life I have no desire to lock myself
away in a room with a bunch of machines
I sort of you know I get sometimes I do
want to lock myself in a room and do it
yeah for some people who don't yet
produce they don't understand that you
just wanna be in a room by yourself with
your stuff and computers and well here's
the way I like to do it I mean a
tracking session yeah is to me is the is
like manna from heaven that's just the
best place to shore you get and it's
hard right because you get a bunch of
musicians together in a room and the
first hour all they want to do is like
hug each other and tell war stories from
yes
see you in a while what's going on and
then they get hungry right so you gotta
order in food daddy and then they're
gonna tune their instruments yeah by
that time you got maybe an hour like a
magic window over now where you go time
you got a block you got to record that
thing and in the old days of analog tape
the head set to be cleaned or on
everything has all lined up well I went
to school at Full Sail so okay dating
myself in the 90s I actually cut tape
right you know that's what they taught
me to do now of course well that stuff
is it's magic you know and it's like to
me what you end up with when you come
away from a session like that those
should be the building blocks when you
go back to block looking yourself away
in your back room sure you know rather
than less you know type in MIDI notes
from scratch you know I like to use I
like I like the organic feel of what
happens when musicians play together in
a room yeah and I'd rather use those as
my as my cookie cutter building blocks
you know and and collage those and tweak
them than just create in the abstract
cuz the thing about machines is they
know nothing about each other sure you
know you tell this bass line to play
with this drum machine and they can do
what they're told but they don't
understand each other and that's what is
happening when musicians play together
so yeah thank you I think we have time
for perhaps one more question
oh sorry folks so I was thinking about
some of the problems you've solved and
I'm wondering how often technological or
creative problems you've solved sort of
through the grit and the hard work and
how often it's been more that
serendipitous moment about thinking
about that young woman's fashion budget
where you just had a thought and then
from that if there's a problem you're
trying to solve right now in the
technologic technology field or perhaps
in the creative yep yeah I always talk
about Thomas Edison and Nikola Tesla you
know Edison had this well-funded lab and
his principle was to design a thousand
experiments and exclude 999 of them
until he came up with the with the right
solution whereas Tesla would get these
blinding moments of
of inspiration and he would invent you
know DC current or you know guided
missiles or the hairdryer
you know these amazing things and he did
that in a badly funded lab you know and
and I have neither the funding nor the
patience of Thomas Edison so I'm
definitely in the Nikola Tesla camp and
I'm willing to forego you know all of
the grit and the hard work and so on
just for that one moment of inspiration
because I think that's actually more
valuable and sometimes that in the
moment it seems like commercially the
wrong thing to do but what I've
discovered from a career of doing it is
that over time you build up this
currency you build up this capital in
consecutive decisions that were the
right artistic decisions and they come
back to serve you well you know as you
get older people get more respectful
your reputation grows and you get to a
certain point in your life where every
new offer that comes in the door this
feels right feels enticing but you're
not afraid to say no to the ones that
just don't click for you very good
ladies and gentlemen Thomas Dolby
[Applause]
Thomas will be signing copies of his
book over in the barns is that right the
activity building yes
and that wraps up book TV's live
coverage of the 15th annual Annapolis
Book Festival
now everything you've seen here today
will air again tonight beginning at
midnight Eastern Time and you can also
watch each individual segment online at
book TV org